Princess Diana a tribute exhibition
officially open now at the shops at
Crystal coinciding with the 25th
anniversary of her passing well Jillian
Lopez from Las Vegas now takes us inside
for a sneak peek of the interactive
experience
well Princess Diana a tribute exhibition
is officially open here at the shops at
Crystal and it is absolutely beautiful
we are inside with the curator himself
David thanks for having us thank you for
coming incredible I it has been a long
time in the making and it's so great to
see it all coming together so right now
we are in kind of like the third room
the big showcase as you enter in through
the exhibit and you might not be able to
tell where we are now but we have to do
the big reveal we're standing on a glass
floor and what are we standing on we'll
walk around and show you a 25-foot train
of Diana's wedding dress this is an
artist in installation exclusively
commissioned for this exhibit and
it's pretty striking believe it or not
this is actually completely fashioned
out of paper oh my gosh this is
absolutely incredible and just one of
the many things that you can see
throughout the exhibit and in this room
everything is interactive you get to
walk through tell us a little bit about
what else is in this room specifically
this room is completely dedicated to her
wedding to Charles whether it's the
seating plan from the private breakfast
the morning before that the queen and
Philip held or it is bridesmaid items
including the flowers she actually
walked down the aisle with or items from
their honeymoon so where did they
actually go where do a princess and a
prince go on honeymoon and you can learn
about all that in this room there's
probably over 50 items in this room that
are authentic from her wedding
um and yeah we just really can't wait to
have people coming in today and checking
it out oh everyone is going to love it
and let's talk about those artifacts and
these items that are found throughout
where did they come from how did you
collect everything so we partnered with
the group The Pink Ravens Crusade
they've been working the last 45 years
to carry this collection and they they
lend out that collection in support of
their cause breast cancer so a portion
of the proceeds from each ticket sold
will be donated to fight breast cancer
wow that is incredible and it's a lot
more than just an exhibit in here
there's so much to learn and why do you
think after all this time even Princess
Diana Still Remains an icon to even us
here in the states
she was an icon because I think her her
influence is actually growing more and
more with time
her compassion for others her love of
family the way she actually changed the
world with humanitarian efforts those
are values that are still so relevant
today maybe even more so so such a role
model that she is is one of the most
significant people of our time well
David thank you for creating such a
beautiful exhibit for everyone to take
in I am so excited for everybody out
here in Las Vegas to see it and there's
so much more to explore so I'll have to
continue making our way through but I'm
really really excited people are going
to love it I think they will I can't
wait for them to all come see it thank
you David thank you